thank you very much in particular I
would like to thank our four speakers so
far for being very disciplined about
time largely in order to make time for
Jonathan Zittrain who was a late but
absolutely fantastic addition I'm
delighted to hand over the substantive
role of sort of tying all of us together
and guiding questions to him I will
however have to take one minute of your
time at the very end so as we approach
the dreaded hour of one o'clock if you
could be absolutely dedicated and
devoted to the conversation that would
be really good and then at that last
moment absolutely dedicated to getting
out of here with maximum elegance that
would be great jonathan is one of these
people who I think needs no introduction
and I was pulling people does he need
one or does he not and a lot of people
said well there's a lot of librarians
here so maybe he actually does he's the
co-director of the Berkman Center for
Internet and Society at Harvard which
has played an enormously important role
in stimulating a broad range of
discussions and debates that that level
and in that forum and also I've done
some remarkable quantitative work of
your / / the / over the years and he has
a book out called the future of the
internet and how to stop it which I
believe was published by yale university
press is that correct I feel like I
ought to play as well as under a
Creative Commons license oh I i hope you
just downloaded the PDF to your kindle
so anyway enough of me Jonathan please
thank you very much
well good morning I come to you without
power point so I feel digitally naked
but facing the daunting task of trying
to give some big picture thoughts to
what has been a lucid and fun and
kaleidoscopic pair of panels this
morning in discussions so I'm so pleased
to be here to be able to hear it and to
to try to share a few thoughts about it
so far I think Jessamine I'm still
processing your talk but I think the
best line of the day still goes to Ted
with here's where the Marxism comes in
bear with me is like that's sort of what
the Soviet Union really was right so but
we digress so um I first tried to think
about some of these library issues that
what I think of is the library one point
Oh meeting and I'm not talking about the
gathering at urbana pool in 700 BC about
clay tablets storage but rather a median
1999 sponsored by a RL and OCLC in
keystone colorado it was a funeral event
on the comment cards a lot of people
were just talking about it was just too
high literally too high up and very dry
but there was a certain feeling I think
that there's this odd combination of
wherein the information economy we know
this is an information a culture
increasingly and yet libraries are
feeling irrelevant and tilting towards
obsolescence that was some of the
feeling in 1999 against a backdrop of an
internet culture of sort of reckless
abandon rejection of any form of history
or context it was just go out I mean
this was the time when a custodial
products company simply renamed itself
b2b e-commerce calm and did an E IPO and
I hope you didn't invest in that your
stock may have died
and uh it's worth thinking about the
fact that Sergey Brin and Larry Page
were graduate students at Stanford they
had some amazing insights about search
which directly led to them abandoning
their studies and starting a calm and I
don't blame them one bit right who could
but there is something about the
relationship between some of these
forces outside the Citadel and what sort
of inside our Citadel that the values we
represent and what's going on that are
worth reflecting on and it makes me try
to think about well what do I understand
as an outsider to the library phenomenon
although just a click away within
academia what is the library and in one
sense I suppose it's a noun it's a
pooling arrangement to deal with the
problem of scarcity why not share a book
around instead of having to have
everybody buy a copy or go without it's
worth thinking on that front that the
first sale doctrine far more obscure
than fair use is truly a keystone that
allows the library to exist it's what
says that even though it is quite likely
costing the publishers money and many of
them if they could deny you this right
to buy a book and lend it in a kind of
organized piracy scheme where people can
put themselves on a list as to wanting
the book next and you can most
efficiently right distribute it around I
mean this is a form of taking money out
of the authors and publishers pockets by
one accounting and yet the first sale
doctrine allows us to do that I suspect
if the publishers could have killed it
they would and then could decide whether
to allow lending at their convenience
but that means that we end up with a big
pile of collections that especially due
to the ethos of thoroughness and care
and knowing that we are trying to save
this stuff for thousands of years the
money that we have often goes into the
preservation of these collections even
as they are in fact increasingly
becoming archives and maybe fewer and
fewer people are finding need for them
and certainly after the Google Books
settlement phenomenon works its way
through one way or the other it's even
that much
likely that having a physical copy of
the book will matter there's certainly a
paradox there too because if the
settlement had provided for utterly free
books let's just suppose the publishers
had like lost their minds for a moment
and said let's just make it free why not
Google thanks for scanning we would
probably cheer that on I know it
requires a bit of a mind bend but we
would cheer it on but in a way it might
put the basic noun function library out
of business because once it's free why
do you need to be warehousing them and
you might say great free at last in both
senses of the word but it's also gets
one to focus on exactly what is the
mission and the relevance of it now
another mission that John Paul free
brought up this morning was library as a
verb the idea of not just having a big
stack of stuff whether digital or
physical but of the act of helping
Shepherd people through it that's
especially notable given his I heard the
gasp that got let out in the crowd as he
shared this from his research that all
of the digital natives they were working
with when asked to look up the Spanish
information about the Spanish Civil War
went to Google a hundred percent of them
googled it and then went to Wikipedia or
it is like oh that doesn't sound good at
least some of them should have gone to
the library which might have directed
them to Google as a resource and then I
was thinking about it and I was like
that's exactly what I would do if I
wanted to research the Spanish Civil War
and you know I Who am I then to complain
about it the other notable thing that
John said right in that couplet of
observations was that zero of the kids
were moved to edit the wiki and he was
sort of just putting that out as but
eventually we'll get there kind of thing
but that shows the kind of work we have
to be done but I think that does
demonstrate the difference between
knowledge is a consumptive good a term
that appears frightening Lee frequently
in the Google Books settlement agreement
consumptive use of the knowledge which
makes me think like is the knowledge
gone
you consume it what comes out the other
end we call that scholarship but if it
raises the question of who owns the
phenomenon say of Wikipedia and can you
encourage the patrons or the kids if
they're in class to imagine owning it in
some way having it actually be something
that they identify with in our part of
and I study internet governance in the
future and past of the internet and
that's the question that the internet
raises for us do we think of the
internet as a shared participatory
phenomenon given its invitation to us to
build upon it without any gatekeepers
it's that invitation that has seen
usually from left field most of the
advances that we then accept as reality
and try to incorporate into what we're
doing that come about so a guy named
Brewster decides to start archiving the
web because someone ought to do it I
mean we might want the web at some point
from the past and just starts doing it
now I don't think it should come as a
surprise and I mean I'm be interested
hear different judgments here the
Internet Archive may well be before the
google books project one of the largest
infringement of copyright in the world
now I say that sort of advisedly because
I love the internet archive we all love
the Internet Archive when you ask
Brewster this kind of question which I
did he kindly participated in the class
of mine a couple years ago he's like
well you know when people call with a
problem we take stuff out I mean it's
like he works it out which is an amazing
human way to provide what is now an
essential function a utility of the
internet and one that did it not occur
to the more institutional pieces of this
landscape to do it was it a money issue
what was it that made it that a guy
would come forward to do it and who's
done it so well rather than that we see
it as so central to what institutionally
and academia were doing the examples
other examples of bound project
gutenberg right michael Hart is just
like let's start typing in public domain
books will get volunteers to type in
books
now this is like a crazy and beautiful
idea and michael Hart is still doing it
right and just you know he's not typing
books he's lengthening his sig file
which is has a number of instructions
and quotes and how to communicate with
him quirky but also one of the central
features I think of that with Steve
Schultz's and others hacking pacer
project maybe with the Cornell lii
taking up the project of just trying to
get simple ad free access to the
nation's statutes and later cases and
yes Wikipedia is an example of this and
the google book scanning project and one
of the most notable things Jeff canard
who you hill from later today was a
guest in my class last week and one of
the things he said was sort of he'll no
doubt correct this but was sort of like
you gotta hand it to the Google guys
like they were just bold enough to start
scanning big piles of books and then get
sued and basically go for double or
nothing right the lawsuit is about their
use which is to produce snippets of
these copyrighted books out to the user
and the lawsuit comes out and what do
they end up with but a class action
settlement that will allow the full text
to be offered on terms that we're still
talking about the favor google but wow
that is a level of boldness that we
don't often see I think emanating
institutionally from academia same with
Amazon taking up the Kindle and sending
up the structures that Ted was talking
about or even setting up search now
there are opportunities here I think for
us to be players not just reactive and I
keep thinking why are we so reactive in
academia reactive isn't always bad it's
the reactive pneus that has us sometimes
on the frontlines challenging the
Patriot Act provisions by which you
might be asked for patron data and not
even allowed to consult a lawyer about
it or the EPA story that we heard from
Mary Alice about pushing back against
things that we know are wrong but it
also means that we miss out on
opportunities to do something larger and
I think this is just hypothesis there's
just a level of carefulness about what
we do sometimes we make the perfect the
enemy of the good and unless we feel we
can do something completely right from
soup to nuts we need the entire do
decimal system before we have a little
bit of folksonomy about us that means
that we end up not quite getting there
and we have a lot of organizations that
try to pull us together but that start
over arching projects that never quite
get finished I think of like the Gowdy
cathedral in not tweezers of gaudy
Cathedral the gal Deacon food Cathedral
in Barcelona it's just this wonderful
work that never quite made it out an
example of that quickly was I was
wondering as a researcher I want to be
able when I visit a link and later want
a sight to the the page I found at the
end of the link i want to be able to
push a button and have it archived in a
library so if there's any question later
it's like there it is there's the page
there's kind of an ancillary function
that the internet archive could be
serving and I was asking the harvard law
librarians why we just don't go out and
build it and they said well there's
actually a harvard university project
called wax mean an ad man for that the
web archive project right acronym wax
and uh yet to do it you have to sign up
you have to get a buddy in the library
system you have to pay I mean it's great
but totally non-functional for the
casual user and most people are that so
I think the lessons I draw from this our
money can go a long way I know we're
always short of it but you know can't we
get an earmark or something in the
context of a trillion dollar bailout
here a nine billion dollar farm bill
there what did it cost to scan those
books somewhere between 100 and 300
million dollars i'm told now on one hand
that's a lot of money on the other hand
by 1999 statistics shopping cart theft
annually in the united states was eight
hundred million dollars so just like
one-eighth of the shopping carts that
disappear could fund the provision of
scanning books in a sense where we could
actually take that on now why aren't we
probably going to do that one is because
well now Google's done it who wants to
scan them all over again and you were
all like I hope the books come back safe
and sound after they go off to be
treated like a sausage factory in the
scanning zone but we do have these gold
copies and when I think about the google
books settlement I'm not going to go at
length on it but these so-called LD
library digital copies that come out of
that settlement there's some real
possibilities there as you might guess
my read of the terms of the settlement
is not being that generous with what
libraries can do with those digital
copies people have been telling you
about the 17-page security guidelines
and you know it's almost safer just to
bury it like radioactive waste that can
hurt you rather than try to make
something of it and when I see terms in
the agreement that say things like
qualified users can access protected
material how's that for humankind's
knowledge it's protected material to
perform computational analysis on the
corpus the research corpus but not to
understand the intellectual content of
the book now not all books assist with
that project anyway but it's an
agreement drafted by lawyers and
business people not one where the
libraries have really had a seat at the
table and I do think there are things we
can do to try to assert ourselves here
and we've seen leadership from people
like and wolpert and others who have
been thinking through these open access
issues so much so when I think about
what is the library really what do we
know it is we know it's a set of values
a set of values sometimes reflected with
the quirky people who have stepped
forward and by quirky that sounds
pejorative we know it's not the web is
quirky the Internet is quirky right and
yet central these values need to be
defended and fought for and inculcated
into our young academics and our
students whether it's k through 12 or
higher ed and see that the spirit that
lives on a little bit in the wiki in
guttenberg in the internet archive can
be reflected in what we do and really
make us at the table trying to build on
this internet even though we know it's
going to cost money and time and there
are so much else to do in the meantime
speaking of time it is short so I'm
going to wrap with that and use the
remaining time we have I know I've been
asked to help moderate some questions
for the panel so I'll say thank you very
much
so I guess we should see if there are
people who want to step up to is it that
microphone are there any others and give
us a quick question provocation anything
else and we have exactly seven minutes
so this is like the last act of an
episode of 24 right the bomb is ticking
can you defuse it I know it's every like
scared nobody also say that yes sir
thank you I think this question would be
to mr. Zimmer please or the whole panel
in light of increased access to all this
technology with viruses and in techno
anarchy what security measures are being
taken to prevent criminal penetration of
identity theft sensitive information
confidential information in other areas
thanks why of course I'm not an
information security expert and I have a
hard time keeping mind my browser safe
the time as well I think one of the main
things that have been done historically
in terms of the collection of any kind
of personal data is attempt to anonymize
that information we hear that talk a lot
more in terms of search search engine
query their attempts to strip out IP
addresses strip out any kind of quote
personally identifiable information
increasingly that's becoming problematic
attempts to do that in a way even that
how data law is here in the US can sort
of frame what is personal identifiable
is quite limited me my name my social
security number sure is person I
personally identifiable but if you
looked at everything I've searched in
the last week you'd probably also figure
out who I am if even if my name is not
in there and they ll search data release
sort of helped by better you know bring
that home that you can just look at
people search queries now identify them
so attempts to anonymize data or just
dropped bits off of an IP address is
what's commonly being done but it's
often insufficient in terms of actual
your repositories there's various
methods of encryption ways that you can
create that as security the finger
systems and that can really speak to the
accuracy of that it's an increasing
challenge just a final example Netflix
data set people that use netflix
understand you can create you know the
cue that you want to give great things
you can say like this I don't like that
the company released that data in an
anonymous form to try to spur innovation
among researchers to build a better
algorithm within about a week some
scientists was able to re identify all
that information by mapping that on top
of people's activity on IMDb and you
start mapping social networks on top of
each other and you can really identify
quite easily so the concern that you're
bringing is an important one and
unfortunately some of the solutions we
have we're going to a certain extent and
there's a lot of really smart people in
the computer science of working on these
problems to try to find better ways to
secure this information of course what I
heard you saying Michael in your
presentation was that that shouldn't
deter the library community from doing
things that might well entail collection
of data not previously collected but
that you just got to be careful with
standards both security and privacy and
maybe even set an example so that you
could ask a company not just our UMC
certified for your data security but are
you up to the library level of
protection for your data and maybe that
can scare them into yeah one of the
examples when we talk about building
widgets affiliate different kinds of
applications because so many of these
tools are built around an advertising
framework can we leverage these
companies to build as a version of this
software where I'm not automatically
collected his dad and that becomes
through this gold standard the library
yeah yeah and I know Ted you're the one
of your big worries about kindle is not
just the money you pay in the way than
which the stuff might get locked up but
in that data that gets generated right
now
part of the talk that I wasn't able to
kind of present on time constraints was
you know the way in which all of that
material gets archived and you know who
knows what will happen I mean it's
interesting to think about Amazon
solvency now I mean they are doing
reasonably well they posted a profit
when lots of other retailers more
posting if they should get but by the
GRU with a yeah you know but what
happens you know if those issues that
they were having financially at the
early part of their days you know
reassert themselves you know and they
have to go bankrupt what happens to all
of that data in it's sort of digital
afterlife you know if they decided to
sell it off who ends up owning how you
read yeah other thoughts well I just
wanted to speak to that production from
our teeny perspective is one of the
library two point O cuadras that we deal
with really in sort of small town
library world is enabling this stuff
we're not building these tools ourselves
we're using other people's tools that's
fine I'm comfortable with other people's
tools but it's not only their what
they're doing with their data which is
mysterious and I think they have a
vested interest in keeping that
mysterious why would they tell me what
they're doing with my data I would say I
didn't want to give it to them but
what's what's also happening is our
users and are the people who run our
libraries aren't sophisticated at a
technical enough level to even
understand you know the anonymizing
features of Firefox and so you have to
have people who know enough to know what
you can do with data and you guys are
all talking about you know anonymizing
kid and we all say the AOL thing and
everyone's like oh yeah because I
searched my own address and then you
know who I am but explaining that to
people who their computers for work and
they don't use it at home and so number
one I mean our library privacy issues
are focused more around can we email a
patron they're overdue notices because
people in Vermont share email addresses
and and it's a totally different thing I
mean my library we write down our names
in the back of the book we're not gonna
next year and does it does it feel a
little bit absurdist that that is I mean
on one hand is a totally genuine worry
on the other given the mountain of stuff
that in the other spheres of your
patrons lives they are exposing and
sharing it almost seems like a teaspoon
in the oceans are
core values versus everybody else core
values and that's what to me makes a
library a library and not you know the
bookstore where you can actually sit I
know the patrons buying what you're
selling when you say that or they like
hells yeah oh they buy what I'm selling
yeah uh-huh got it Michael you wanted
the last word or the last word I have
many last words but this point that
never bringing up in terms of specially
we make that comparison to what is
Amazon doing with the data I think this
is the real opportunity for libraries to
stand up and save work even if we're
collecting his information let's be
transparent let's give access Google
actually made an important step in this
direction when they announced their
behavioral targeting scheme a few weeks
ago that to a very very very very very
limited extent you can click through and
see what they're collecting about you
and how they're profiling you and they
get its to that I'd like to see that at
the my new detail level if I'm if we're
going to have a recommendation system
amazon has all this amazing data about
me I don't get to see any but if
Milwaukee Public Library wants to
collect that data about me let me look
at let me delete information from let me
correct it let me sort of fudge it if I
wanted to punch which almost makes it
sound again pointing towards the google
books discussion that's going to take
place that may be a real opportunity as
a single bir books rights registry is
going to be created that's going to
interact with google you've got this
database stuff getting tracked maybe
there is some role for external
involvement in the public interest to
make sure that those things are
respected Ted you have an important
secret announcement that can now be
unveiled for the minute for which
everybody must pay close attention
fantastic i feel like i'm in the price
is right except that i was already up
here during the lunch break there will
be three birds of a feather meetings
through one on privacy that's being
hosted or attracted by Michael Zimmer
over here there's another one on pacer
and surrounding issues again being sort
of attracted by
Mary Alice oh sorry there's a second one
on pacer that Mary Alice and Stephen
Schmitz will be hosting and a third one
on the Google Books settlement by emmel
and so wonderful thank you very much for
your time and attention I hope you
enjoyed it thank you very much